ja und wir schauen direkt auf schüsse
mitten in der innenstadt schwer
bewaffnete polizeibeamte in wuppertal
einen großeinsatz der polizei dort lief
am pfingstsonntag ein mann mit einem
messer in der hand herum und bedroht
passanten und beamte
es sind szenen wie aus einem kinofilm
mehrere beamte der polizei wuppertal
stehen am pfingstsonntag im stadtteil
elberfeld vor einem mann umzingeln dann
fallen schüsse
[Musik]
doch was genau war passiert
am späten sonntagnachmittag ist ein mann
in wuppertal mit einem messer in der
hand herum im stadtteil elberfeld
bedroht der unbekannte passanten mit
seiner waffe anwohner alarmierten
daraufhin die polizei etliche
streifenwagen rasen zum tatort vor ort
fordern die beamten den mann immer
wieder auf das messer wegzulegen setzen
sogar pfefferspray ein und feuern einen
warnschuss ab doch der mann reagiert
überhaupt nicht zeigt sich offenbar
unbeeindruckt schlimmer noch der
unbekannte zieht plötzlich selbst eine
pistole und zielt damit auf die beamten
erneut fordern die einsatzkräfte den
mann mehrmals auf seine waffe
niederzulegen doch keine reaktion in
notwehr eröffnen sie anschließend das
feuer
der unbekannte wird getroffen und kommt
in eine klinik nach bild informationen
soll es sich bei seiner waffe um eine
spielzeugpistole gehandelt haben warum
der mann mit einem messer in der hand
durch wuppertal herumirrte ist noch
unklar zu den hintergründen und abläufen
des geschehens ermitteln jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft wuppertal und die
polizei hagen aus neutralitätsgründen
[Musik]
bei uns ist unser chef reporter frank
schneider mit allen hintergründen zu
diesem fall franck der mann da wurde
angeschossen wurde verletzt was weiß der
war sein gesundheitszustand
dahin geht es mittlerweile in umständen
entsprechend ganz gut am klang es war
natürlich lebensgefahr nicht
auszuschließen muss immer überlegen wenn
google so einen körper treffen können
auch große blutgefäße verletzt werden es
kann dazu starken inneren blutungen auch
kommen zum glück ist es insofern
glimpflich ausgegangen dass er
mittlerweile außer lebensgefahr ist auch
wohl auf normalstation mittlerweile und
jetzt muss man hoffen dass er ganz
schnell wieder gesund wird frank was
bedeutet es dann auch für die polizei
wenn sie auf einen mann schießen der
eigentlich nur eine spielzeugpistole in
der hand hält was müssen die beamten
jetzt befürchten
die beamten können natürlich innerhalb
von sekundenbruchteilen nicht erkennen
ob es sich um eine echte oder eine nicht
echte waffe handelt das ist ja häufig
das problem es gibt ja auch seit dem
mittlerweile ich glaube seit fünf jahren
ungefähr dieses
anscheinswaffe also eine anscheinswaffe
kann auch eine softair waffe sein kann
eine spielzeugwaffe sein sie sehen ja
mittlerweile echt aus und gerade wenn
man auch die örtlichkeit dort sie das
ist unter bäumen schatten wie sollen die
beamten in dem moment erkennen denn der
vorstand einem messer umgebracht hat was
handel bedroht ist aggressiv aufgetreten
und plötzlich zieht ja dann aus seiner
jacke noch eine pistole und richtete sie
auf die beamten die können ja gar nicht
in dem moment unterscheiden das ist eine
echt oder ist es keine echte waffe und
wenn er sie nicht widerlegt dann haben
sie eben geschossen das nennt man in der
rechtsprechung die sogenannte kreative
notwehr das heißt die beamten gehen
davon aus dass er sie mit einer echten
waffe bedroht können dass momentan auch
nicht anders klären und dürfen deshalb
in der regel ausschließen dass uns
natürlich jetzt die staatsanwaltschaft
lernen durften sie schießen oder nicht
aber ich gehe mal davon aus bei diesem
fall ist es relativ eindeutig dass sie
von der schusswaffe gebrauch machen
durfte es hat inzwischen mehr
hintergründe über ein mögliches motiv
und auch über diesen informationen über
den mann bekannt geworden
ja es ist so dass er immer noch polizei
bekannt ist soll wie gesagt sich um
psychische auffälligkeiten zum einen
handeln aber zum anderen soll er auch im
bereich der drogenkriminalität bekannt
sein es kann also auch sein dass er
möglicherweise bei der tat das müssen
auch jetzt in versuchung auch klären
welche sachen drogeneinfluss gestanden
hat und dann würde es auch erklären
warum man zum beispiel auch nach den
schüssen nachdem auch betroffen ist die
waffe immer noch nicht widerlegen es ist
ja so dass man auch in dem video
teilweise hörten sie ihn weiter an
schreien auch nach entschlossen und
horten ist das so wenn menschen unter
drogeneinfluss stehen spüren sie auch
schmerzen nicht so stark oder gar nicht
in möglicherweise wie in einem drittel
und das würde vielleicht auch erklären
seine seine vorgehensweise es gibt auch
leider immer wieder die fälle suicide by
cop also eben selbstmord bei einem
polizisten es kann natürlich hier auch
so sein dass er möglicherweise in seiner
psychischen ausnahmesituationen auch
bewusst provozieren wollte
möglicherweise nicht mehr leben wollte
aber das müssen jetzt die ermittlungen
im einzelnen klären stand jetzt ist dass
die polizisten jedenfalls nach ersten
ermittlungen auch schießen durften und
das ist dem bankrott sei dank wieder
wissen vielen dank frank schneider für
deine aktuelle informationen dort aus
essen